REST & VESTERS:
That was a Twitter tech lead admitting that
he and most of his colleagues only work 4
hours every week.
Despite this terrible performance, this guy
was likely paid around $341,000 every single
year.
Put another way, he was basically getting
paid over $1,600 per hour.
Clearly, Elon put an end to this at Twitter
but this is still very much a reality within
most tech companies.
Now, I don’t want to throw all engineers
under the bus as a substantial portion of
them are the exact opposite, working 60 to
80 hours every week.
But with that being said, there is a signifcant
number of engineers just like this.
In fact, this “community” is so large
that there’s a name for people like this
“rest and vesters”.
They just rest and vest their insanely high
compensation packages.
You would think that managers hate these type
of people and that they’re constantly looking
to expose and fire these freeloaders but that’s
not actually the case.
In fact, a lot of managers do this themselves
and they sometimes even encourage their team
to do it as well.
This one high level engineer at Facebook for
example was making a million per year and
leading about 36 people.
While the pay and prestige was great, she
was getting pretty burnt out with her job,
so she did the respectable thing and told
her boss who was likely a senior director
that she was going to leave in about 6 months.
She was willing to finish up all the projects
that she had already taken on but didn’t
want anymore.
To this, her boss told her to not come to
work the next day.
In any other industry or even a legacy tech
company, this means: You’re fired, don’t
bother showing up tomorrow.
At Facebook though this meant "Just don’t
come to work.
You're burned out and need a break.
Just don’t talk about it and everyone will
assume you're on someone else’s team."
Clearly, this is a not a group of rebels that
are pushing the boundaries.
This is a systematic trend at these companies.
Many companies are cracking down on this with
layoffs more recently, but for the most part,
they just turn a blind eye to the entire situation.
So, here’s why FAANG engineers are allowed
to work so little while getting paid so much.
FRIENDLY ECONOMICS:
One of the biggest factors that makes resting
and vesting possible is simply the economics
of these companies.
Unlike a factory or a bottling plant, these
tech companies have insanely high gross margins.
Apple 43%.
Google 55%.
Nvidia 56%.
And Facebook 78%.
So, really, their only major expense is human
labor as their cost of goods sold is virtually
zero.
In fact, at Visa, the gross margin is straight
up 100%.
As for the tech companies that don’t have
high gross margins yet, well they usually
just have infinite VC funding so they end
up in the same boat.
With that being said, the top priority for
leaders of these companies is to simply reach
as many people as possible as quickly as possible,
to maximize growth.
Efficiency is not something that they have
ever really prioritized until recently and
it’s no wonder why.
Focusing on growth is simply way more beneficial.
Here’s the thing, these companies are usually
able grow 30 to 50% per year for multiple
decades straight.
Amazon for example hasn’t even had a single
quarter of negative revenue growth since the
beginning of this chart.
So, it makes no sense to focus on the 20 or
30% of employees that are leeches or worse
get the people who are working hard to waste
time weeding out these freeloaders when leaders
can just focus on growing the entire company
by 50%.
But all of that is just half the puzzle.
The other half is that the employees also
enjoy super friendly economics.
If an engineer is living paycheck to paycheck
and struggling to make rent, you can bet that
they’re gonna work hard to keep their job.
But, this is rarely the case with engineers.
If anything, they’re struggling to keep
up with their upscaled silicon valley life
with their $2 million mortgage and tesla model
s plaid.
Realistically though, these engineers have
absolutely no problem paying for a base standard
of living especially with remote work becoming
more popular.
In other words, they’re not exactly dependent
on their jobs so they’re not exactly scared
of getting fired.
In fact, they often don’t even care for
their job.
They’re not looking for a promotion or to
climb to ladder or to do something impactful.
The only reason they’re still working at
the company is to cash in on the stock compensation
that unlocks in 12 or 24 months and then hopefully
score another large package right after that.
If they don’t get the package they’re
looking for, they’ll just jump ship to another
company who will pay them what they want.
Now, you might be saying, who would hire such
a bum.
Well, the number one factor that gets you
a job at these companies is how well you interview
and how well you can solve coding problems.
And guess what, these guys are stars at this.
That’s how they got their original job itself.
They know what to do, they just choose not
to do it.
So, unless their previous manager gives them
just an absolutely awful referral, if they’re
even asked for a referral, these people are
able to just jump from job to job and coast
as needed.
So, if you wanna fire them, go ahead, they’ll
just turn around and find better paying jobs
anyway.
NO NEED:
Aside from the financials working out, the
reality is that there’s often just not much
to do at many of these jobs to begin with.
When someone hears that you work at Google,
they instantly assume that you must be working
on something super cool or at least something
familiar.
Maybe you’re working on the YouTube algorithm
or Google ads or even Google Bard but only
the elite of the elite get to be on these
teams.
Everyone else is just tasked with the monotonous
work of maintaining and upgrading their existing
systems.
In other words, the average Googler isn’t
strategizing how Bard can overtake ChatGPT.
Rather, they’re probably working on the
423rd iteration of a Google places API that
will likely never see the light of day along
with 5 other engineers.
The purpose of this iteration is to reduce
request times from 0.75 of a second to 0.5
a second for Apple M1 devices.
The team probably optimized the code within
a matter of hours but now they’re waiting
days for approval from upper management.
In the meantime, they’re just writing some
documentation and having useless meetings
as they wait to go home everyday.
That is unfortunately the scope of most engineers
in big tech.
Obviously not that exciting and not that different
from traditional jobs.
As these companies grew, so did their inefficiencies
and bureaucracy and so many engineers are
just simply stuck between the wheels.
Now, an active employee might ask to be placed
on more teams and take on more work.
But, for a passive employee who’s willing
to do what they’re asked but nothing more,
there’s simply not much more to do than
20 hours of work per week which brings us
into our next type of rest and vester which
is the 10X engineer.
10X engineers aren’t exactly trying to work
as little as possible and just coast.
In fact, they may be actively going for a
promotion.
They just don’t need all that much time
to kill it at their job.
When you think about it, this is really not
that surprising.
Given that these companies are looking to
hire the best talent possible for whatever
price, it’s only natural that they attract
a substantial number of super stars.
These people are simply able to achieve what’s
expected or even go above and beyond within
a matter of 20 hours a week.
And given that most tech companies value results
over hours worked, these people fit right
in.
Netflix for example offers unlimited paid
time off.
The reason being that they don’t care about
you clocking in everyday.
They care about what value you provide and
these 10X engineers more than carry their
weight.
So, despite working a low number of hours,
these engineers aren’t exactly resting.
They’re simply super productive when they
do work and they likely have several major
commitments outside of their job like working
on a startup or running a YouTube channel.
The bottomline is that unless you’re aggressively
trying to climb the corporate ladder, there’s
simply no need to work any more whether you’re
a passive engineer or a 10X engineer.
PART OF THE PLAN:
Much of what we discussed so far simply seems
to be circumstantial.
Tech companies just happen to have great economics
and inefficiencies and bureaucracy and all
of that.
But really, the only reason that rest and
vesters exist is because these companies want
them to exist.
In fact, not only do they want them to exist,
they were literally the ones who created them.
You see, the history of the rest and vesters
dates back to the origins of these companies.
The first 50 engineers.
The first 100 engineers.
These guys were the OG rest and vesters.
Hold on back up, how could these guys have
been resting and vesting when the company
was at it’s most critical state.
Well, they weren’t atleast not for the first
5 or 10 years.
Back then, they were actually busting their
butts scaling Google or Facebook or whatever
else.
But eventually, the company makes it to the
other side.
They become profitable, they hire large teams,
all the groundwork has been laid.
In the meantime, the original workforce has
also become extraordinarily rich.
Each of them probably only got like a 0.1%
stake in the company but that itself is worth
tens of millions if not hundreds of millions.
So, where do these people go from here?
Well, the most logical step would be to just
retire but these guys aren’t usually the
retiring type.
They’re more likely to join another startup
at an executive level position or found their
own startup likely in an adjacent field.
And see, this is where the problem arises.
Given that these guys have been around since
the beginning, they’re well aware of all
of the mistakes Google or Facebook made along
the way and how to avoid these if they did
it again.
This makes these individuals a massive asset
for startups but also a massive liability
for Google and Facebook.
For obvious reasons, these companies don’t
want their early employees to help out or
even create competitors.
So, they go to these employees and tell them:
Hey Jeff, we know how hard you’ve worked
over the past 10 years and how instrumental
you’ve been for this company.
So, we’d like to give you a $100 million
stock package and the title of senior VP.
Only caveat is that you have to stick around
for another 10 years to unlock the entire
package by which point that’ll actually
be worth a billion so you definitely wanna
stick around.
In the meantime, of course do a good job as
SVP but you don’t have to work to the bone
or anything and that’s where it all begins.
These companies are essentially bribing these
employees to not leave.
They don’t even care how effective they
are as employees.
As long as they don’t become effective employees
for other companies, that’s a win.
Originally, this strategy was only reserved
for the most elite employees but it has since
worked its way down the corporate ladder.
A senior manager at Google for example could
easily switch to being an extremely pivotal
director or even VP at a startup.
So, Google basically just hands them half
a million a year and tells them to chill out.
Likely the best evidence of this is Google’s
hiring strategy.
Till recently, they didn’t even know what
team their hires would end up in because they
didn’t hire based on need.
They would just post generic job listings
like Software Engineer.
It wasn’t until they test and verify your
skills that they even tried to find a team
for you.
With every hire, they’re basically like:
Oh shoot, this guys actually skilled.
We can’t let him work somewhere else.
Uh, let’s just find a team for him.
And that’s why FAANG engineers work so little
but earn so much.
It’s because it’s all part of the bigger
plan.
ChatGPT has taken this to the next level with
$900,000 salaries.
Check out this video to learn more.